#HASHTAGWARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
AS I MENTIONED, THE PHILADELPHIA
BREWERY IS MAKING BEER USING
GOAT BRAINS IN HONOR OF THE
WALKING DEAD, BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WALKING DEAD HAS ALL THE GOAT
BRAINS ON IT.
WITH THAT IN MIND, TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG IS #BADBOOZE.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE "LOWER
MANHATTANS" OR "SLIPPERY
SUPERFLUOUS NIPPLES" OR
"MILLER VIETNAM DRAFT."
(LAUGHTER)
I'LL PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, AND GO!
MEGAN.
>> HIV-POSITIVE BLOODY MARYS.
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: THE CROWD IS
SUPPORTING IT.
I WILL GIVE IT POINTS.
BEN.
>> MINT JEW LIPS.
(LAUGHTER)
JEW LIPS.
COME ON.
>> Chris: GREG PROOPS, CAN YOU
PLEASE COMPLETE THE TRIFECTA
OF OFFENSIVENESS?
>> SURE: PABST SMEAR.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: WELL DONE.
A DELICIOUS CHERRY ON TOP
FOR POINTS.
MEGAN NEURINGER.
>> THIS IS GOING TO REALLY
DIVIDE PEOPLE, BUT "SHIRLEY
TEMPLE GRAVE JUICE."
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
>> Chris: HEY, HEY, HEY!
YOU DIDN'T KNOW HER!
(LAUGHTER)
BEN.
>> SCHLONG ISLAND ICED TEA.
>> Chris: SCHLONG ISLAND ICED
TEA?
>> SCHLONG ISLAND ICED TEA.
>> Chris: I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS
FOR THAT.
PROOPS.
>> I SEE YOUR SCHLONG ISLAND
ICED TEA AND I'LL SAY
"PENAL COLONIC."
(LAUGHTER)
>> ♪ IF YOU LIKE PENAL
COLONICS... ♪
>> Chris: YOU GOT BOTH WORDS,
EXCELLENT.
>> ♪ YOU BETTER (BLEEP) ON ME
>> ♪ WHEN YOU WOULD OPEN UP
YOUR JEW LIPS
IT'S HIV BLOODY MARY... ♪
>> Chris: ARE YOU NOW SINGING
"ESCAPE (THE PINA COLADA SONG)"
WITH ALL THE SUBMISSIONS
FROM THE GAME?
>> YEAH, THAT WAS THE IDEA.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: THAT IS THE END OF